I've been in business for 13 years. I've
sold nine companies. My last company I
sold for 46.2 million. I own
acquisition.com, which right now does
about $17 million a month across our
portfolio. I'm going to compress 13
years of brutal business truths and
lessons into this one video. Brutal
business truth number one. Sell to rich
people until you have the money to sell
all the poor people. The middle is where
you get killed. Elon said, "You can
either do a lot of good for a small
amount of people or a little good for a
large amount of people." And I will tell
you personally, it's a way harder to do
a little good for a lot of people than a
lot of good for a small amount of
people. There is a reason that Tesla
started at the top. They started only
selling to rich people. They had the
Roadster, which was $250,000. And so
they sold those, and then he was able to
go down market one and sell $100,000
cars to just upper echelon of society,
the wealthy. And then after that, he
made the X, which is a little bit
cheaper than that. And then underneath
of that, he made the Model 3, which was
going to be the mass model car. Right?
And each time, it was significantly
harder to do the one before because if
if you want to sell based on value in
terms of low cost,
you need to build the infrastructure for
huge amounts of demand because the only
way that you make money selling to poor
people is selling tons and tons and tons
of them. Look at Walmart. Look at
Amazon. These are businesses that were
built for volume day one, and they win
on efficiency. That was the whole point.
Amazon, he wanted to have the best
selection and the lowest prices.
Walmart, everyday low prices. They want
to They win on efficiencies. Like, they
all fly coach. They use fold-out chairs.
They drink out of paper cups. They
purposely breed the culture of
efficiency because it's the only way
that you can win if you sell to poor
people. And I say poor people to be
hyperbolic in terms of my language so
that it drives the point home.
Obviously, I buy from Amazon. But the
point is is that the strategy is based
on volume.
And you've probably heard some of my
other tweets around this, which is solve
rich people problems, they pay better.
Or if you solve rich people problems,
you get to charge rich people prices.
This is what I think the key inside is.
Is that to someone who only has a
thousand dollars, when they pay you a
hundred dollars, they pay you ten
percent of their net worth. Their
expectations of what they're going to
get for that hundred dollars is the same
as a rich person giving you ten million
of their hundred million dollars. It
would be gigantic, right? In terms of
their expectations. But getting a rich
person to give you a hundred dollars,
they might not even notice. And so the
thing is is that it's actually easier in
some ways to solve rich people problems
because they're willing to pay more in
an absolute sense for lower relative
value.
And so with that extra profit or gross
margin, you can absolutely over deliver
for them and still make money and not
have to learn all these things with
infrastructure. So for example, if I
wanted to start a bank, I would have to
have twenty-five to a hundred million
dollars to start it up. But if you do
that, then you have to build the
infrastructure that you can handle money
for zillions and zillions and zillions
of people. A very hard business to get
into. And so the idea is that you want
to sell, at least this is my belief, is
that you want to sell premium, you want
to sell to wealthy people, you want to
sell to a niche person that you can do a
lot of good for in a very small slice
because you don't have to compete
against everyone, you can have
inefficiencies and still make money
without having to have tremendous
infrastructure and skill around building
it.
Once you make a ton of money doing that,
you can obviously just do more of that,
which big fan.
Or you say, you know what, the next
thing I do, I want to do for zillions
and zillions of people.
And so then you build a business like a
Netflix that Think about how insane
Netflix is, just as a concept. You pay
thirteen dollars or fifteen dollars a
month or whatever it is now.
And they create movies and shows and
they spend millions of dollars and they
sign comedians and they've got all these
shows that are streaming and you pay
fourteen dollars a month. It's absurd.
Think about if you were said, hey mom
and dad, I want to start this video
subscription and I'm going to just pay
millions of dollars to get all these
shows and movies made for us, and I'm
just going to charge 14 bucks. It would
be absurd.
That's how much value you have to
provide to someone who doesn't have
money to capture huge slices of the
market. How are you going to beat Prime?
$99 a year or $129 a year, whatever it
is now, right?
And with Prime, you get basically all of
Netflix with Prime Video. You also have
next-day shipping, same-day shipping
with anything that you want to buy.
99 bucks a year, 100 $129 a year.
If you build to sell to the masses, you
need to build like you're going to sell
to the masses, and you're usually going
to have to put a ton of money in for a
long period of time because you have to
have that infrastructure up front to
deal with that volume, to have such a
crazy value discrepancy that someone who
has no money still never wants to
cancel.
That's the key.
Whereas, if you go to wealthier people,
you can get a premium. You can have five
clients that all pay you $5,000 a month
and make an amazing income and have the
resources to actually do a good job and
hire a couple people to help you out who
are competent. And you can do that when
you charge more money, and those people
are out the ones who are like and you
Everybody's heard seen this meme where
the $50 a month customer is like, "Hey,
so for this $50 a month, what am I going
to get?" Now, we make fun of that.
That's the reality of if you're taking
5% of someone's paycheck,
it means a lot to them.
Whereas, if you're going to somebody
who's making a million a month, and they
pay you five grand, if they get one good
thing a year, they're stoked.
And they're like, "Oh, yeah, I sent the
wire. Did you get it?"
Like the difference between working with
somebody who's on the lower end versus
the higher end.
And so, being very clear about who you
serve, not serving other people, going
down market only if you have the
infrastructure to support huge amounts
of volume, and usually the capital to
front it.
Either you build for volume day one and
win on efficiency like Amazon or
Walmart, or you build for a premium,
which means you niche down and you
completely solve problems for people.
So, you completely solve a problem in a
very narrow niche. And so, let me give
you a completely polar opposite examples
here, which I literally live on both
sides of the spectrum. On one side,
acquisition.com is my premium brand,
right? This is the brand that we do
deals with. This is where we have
hundred million dollar companies and
stuff that we invest in that we own it,
right? That's my family office and we do
one or two deals a year. Just to be
really, really We make very rich people
way wealthier, right? That's what I do
there. So, someone comes in is already
worth 50 million bucks and we're like,
"Cool, how do we get to 250?" And that's
what we invest in and that's what we we
scale the company.
On the other extreme,
we've got School.
So, School is for everyone who's
starting out. Now, School took 5 years
to get to the level of product that it
is now and millions and tens of millions
of dollars of development where it lost
money the entire time and still loses
money right now
in order to create such an absurd value
for the 99 bucks a month or whatever it
is. Cuz we know that that 99 dollars a
month for somebody who's trying to start
their business, that's the entirety of
their business budget. And so, we have
to solve all of the business problems
that those people have at that level.
And so, these are two completely This I
mean, honestly, the most polar extremes
of value creation in terms of
who we're selling to or who we advertise
to and who we're attracting and how we
help them. And so, there's no
coincidence that I did acquisition.com
before investing in being a co-owner of
School
because I had to make enough money to be
able to afford to sell to people who
don't have much
to be able to to help build the
infrastructure and invest millions of
dollars to build that so that we could
accommodate millions and millions of
users. Right now, we have many millions
of users on the platform. If you are
confused about how to sell rich people
stuff,
first off, the easiest hack for selling
to rich people is
do what somebody else is doing that
sells to rich people and do it in half
the time and charge twice the price.
Number one,
rich people pay for time above all else.
But if we look at the value equation,
you've got the outcomes, you got to make
sure they want the outcome that you're
promising. And then you got the three
other variables. You've got risk, how
likely is it that they're going to get
what they want when they buy,
time, delay between when they buy and
when they get, and the effort and
sacrifice. The richer they are, the more
guaranteed they want it to be. Now, you
don't have to guarantee things, but you
need the perception of the guarantee.
That's why reputation matters. If you're
the best plastic surgeon in the world,
you don't give a guarantee, they just
have a high perceived likelihood of
achievement. They believe that if they
pay you, the likelihood that their nose
isn't up when they do the surgery
is high.
If time delay, they want it to be as
fast as possible. If they give you money
and have it tomorrow,
rich people pay a lot of money for that.
And then, you've got effort and
sacrifice. Well, I don't want to do
anything, I want you to do everything.
And so, the thing is is that a lot of
times it makes sense to have very white
glove, concierge, high touch things for
people who are willing to pay for it
because for them, the incremental
difference in cost for them is actually
very small. So, the difference between
$5,000 a month and $10,000 a month to a
multimillionaire, not a huge difference.
But if you're just better for $10,000 a
month, they'll happily pay you than the
$5,000 a month guy. You're not going to
sell somebody who's wealthy on how much
money you're going to save them, you'll
sell someone who's wealthy on how much
time you're going to save them.
Brutal business truth number two,
you lack priorities, not information.
Problems are easy to solve if you know
what you're after. If you know what
problem you're actually trying to solve.
I'll tell you a story. So, I was talking
to an entrepreneur who's doing about 10
million a year. And that was between all
of his companies. And we were talking
and he mentioned a one and then he
mentioned a second, he mentioned a
third, he mentioned a fourth. I was
like, "Dude, how many companies do you
have?" And he's like, "Oh, I don't
know." I was like, "You don't know?"
He's like, "Yeah, I have an Excel
sheet."
And so, I was like, "Well, pull it up."
And so, he pulled up his Excel sheet and
he had like 56 companies that in total
were making like $10 million a year. And
obviously one of them was the biggest
one that was doing like half of that
revenue. And that was was the company
that I had heard of that that he that he
founded. I said,
"Dude, if you just only had that one
company, how
easy would it be to like 5x that
business?" He was like, "Oh my god, if I
didn't have the other 55 companies, it'd
be a it'd be a joke." I was like, "So,
if I waved the magic wand and that
happened, you think you could do it?"
And he was like, "Yeah." And I was like,
"Then do it. You can wave the magic
wand. You can end these other 55
partnerships so that you can do this one
thing."
And what's crazy is that a year later I
talked to him
and he had done just that. He was like,
"Dude, I like didn't sleep for 3 days
after we talked because I was like, 'Oh
my god, that's it.'" So, I see strategy
as priority. It's prioritization of
resources, right? You have unlimited
options, but you have limited resources,
time, money, people, etc. And so, how
you choose to allocate those resources
against the unlimited options is your
strategy. It is how you prioritize. And
when you have one clear goal for one
clear company for one clear customer,
the prioritization actually gets pretty
easy.
And so, a lot of people will keep
looking for these unique insights when
the reality is you don't even have a
goal.
Have you defined the problem that you're
trying to solve?
And most people have it. And that ends
up being usually the first question I
ask someone. They're like, "Hey, I'm
stuck with my business." And I just say,
"Well, what's the goal?" And then they
say something. I say, "Well, what
problem are you solving right now?"
And so, if you can't clearly state
current state, desired state, obstacle,
you're running around like a chicken
with your head cut off. You're not going
to solve anything. You're going to do a
lot of work,
but you're not going to move forward.
So, I had a media company approach me.
They've got 40 million subscribers
across their channels. Obviously very,
very good at media. They said, "Hey,
we've been listening to your content and
we think that our constraint, like the
problem that we need to solve, that will
get us the most bang for the buck, is
that we need to optimize our SOPs for
the media company." I said, "Okay, well,
what's the goal?" I was like, "Is it to
just get more famous or is it to make
money?" And they're like, "No, know,
want to we want to shift into
monetization now." I was like, "Okay."
So,
let me ask you this, what product do you
sell?
And they were like, "Well, we don't have
a product."
I was like, "Okay.
So, hear me out, crazy idea.
If you had a product,
you would make a lot more money than
trying to get your 97 out of 100 media
company to 98 and a half. Not to say
that there's nothing like if they said,
"I want to be more famous." then I would
have said, "Absolutely, you should do
that. That makes sense." because
monetization isn't the goal. But, if
they were trying to make money, they had
nothing to sell. And I promise you, if
you have nothing to sell, you make a lot
less money than if you do have something
to sell.
And so, they could be a two out of 10 on
product, but with that amount of media,
that amount of traffic,
they would be able to get so many sales
that they would they would blow it out
of the water. And so, they were spending
all this time trying to get in the
intricacies, trying to get information
on how to solve the wrong problem.
And so, most times, it's not that you
lack insight, it's that you're solving
the wrong thing.
And I think the reason that that
happened so frequently is because those
entrepreneurs are media entrepreneurs.
They like media. They feel comfortable
in media. And so, they like solving
media problems. And so, they like
solving problems that they know how to
solve because they've solved them
before. I'll tell you a different story.
I had a
guy who came out for a workshop here at
acquisition.com and he said, "Hey, can
you go over the closer framework?" And I
said, "Okay. You flew across the
country. You've been here for a day. You
have this one opportunity to ask this
question to me." I was like,
"Is sales a problem in your business?
What's your close rate?" He said, "40%."
I said, "So, sales is not the constraint
in your business." He was like, "No." I
was like, "Then why are you asking me
about the closer framework?"
And I actually think that that lesson
was way more powerful than me trying to
go over the closer framework because the
reality is this, he was a sales guy. He
loves selling. And so, he wanted to hear
me talk about sales, but sales isn't the
problem in his business.
There's something else that's the
problem. He might not be getting enough
leads or people are turning out to to
click on the back end or he can't even
take on more customers cuz he doesn't
have enough team. Like, those are all
other examples of problems that might
exist and I'll bet you one of those
three probably is the problem in his
business, but that wasn't the question
he asked. He asked about the thing that
he enjoyed reading about, the favorite
thing he enjoyed learning about. And so
right now, if you're an entrepreneur, it
is true that you want to double down on
your strengths, but the business as a
whole has to be balanced. So hear me
out. If you think about business like uh
like a body, okay? And you're a
bodybuilder, and so you want to have
ideal ratios for everything in terms of
like if your arms were like this big and
your and your your quads were tiny, then
you look weird, right? So you want to be
a specialist. Like you, sure, as an
individual contributor, keep doubling
down on your strengths, but the business
as a whole will only be as strong as its
weakest link. And so this is where
people get confused with double down on
your strength versus be well balanced.
The business needs to be balanced. Your
physique in total needs to be balanced,
but you as an individual contributor can
double down on your strengths. You want
a team of people who are all doubling
down on their strengths, but you as the
organizer of the business need to make
sure that the business as a whole is
balanced, otherwise it will get
constrained at some point, and then that
point will be your point of failure.
That will be the weak link. That will be
the part of the bridge where only $1 can
get across, even though you've got 10x
the front end and 10x the back end, that
one bottleneck is what's bottlenecking
the business. And so making sure that
often times the thing that you're not
the most excited about, if you're a
marketing entrepreneur, marketing's
probably not your problem. If you're
product-driven entrepreneur, product's
probably not your problem. If you hate
people,
and that's like that's probably your
issue. Like I hate meetings, I hate
leading people, I hate trying to
reinvent my team. I'll bet you that you
probably are having limits on your
business because you don't know how to
recruit, hire, train, manage.
And so that's actually what you need to
either learn or recruit someone who
already knows how to do that. And so
people spend too much time mentally
masturbating to the concepts that they
love in the idea that because it worked
to get them to where they're at, because
they needed to start marketing to make
money, they think, "Okay, now if I 10x
marketing, that that's what it takes to
make more money." And unless that's the
constraint, that's not true. And often
times businesses do grow to the
constraint of the founder, they do grow
to the
constraint of that individual founder's
highly specialized skill, and then at
that point it's constrained with
something else that the founder doesn't
like as much. And so either you got to
learn it and get comfortable learning
stuff that you don't like as much
initially, or you got to find someone
who does.
And so if you're like, "Okay, well, I'm
either a product entrepreneur and I need
more marketing or I'm a marketing
entrepreneur and I need more product or
I'm either of those things and we don't
have an operator, we have somebody who
likes to lead and manage people and
invest in teams." Then how do you know
what good looks like? So first off, one
of the biggest advantages of business of
of doing this for a while is that you
start to recognize patterns. So you hire
five guys that suck and then finally you
find a sixth then all of a sudden you're
like, "Okay, so this is what a good
sales director looks like." This is why
the businesses, for example, that we
start now grow so much faster because
one, we know who's going to be needed
next and two, we know what that person
looks like. And so think about how much
time you save where if the constraint,
let's say, is sales and you hire,
onboard, train and that takes a month
and then that person sucks and it takes
you six months to fire them. And then
you do it again and that takes another
six months to fire them. You do it again
and then this time it works. Well, you
just wasted a year and change of growth
that you should have been growing but
you weren't because you had the wrong
person at the point of constraint. And
realistically, this is why so many
businesses get stuck. And the wrong
conclusion is the person says, "Oh, I
tried hiring sales directors. That
doesn't work." No, you tried hiring
John. And John sucked. It doesn't mean
that there is no sales director. It
doesn't mean you're the special
snowflake that no one can ever replace
you or that no one can do this role.
It's just that you can't. Like there's
Microsoft, there's Facebook, there are
gazillion-dollar companies. Someone out
there on Earth is better than you
literally at the thing that you're best
at and definitely better than the thing
that you suck at. Now, how do you
actually tactically find these people
when you don't have the experience? So
I'll give you the the tactics how I
think about this.
One is that interview lots of people.
And so if you think about the interview
process as an education process in
asking them as much as you possibly can,
act like an ignoramus. Just be like, I
don't know anything about this. Tell me
about it. And then
don't then immediately jump on the first
person. Go on 10 dates. Go on 20 dates.
I'll give you a little sideline story.
For school, Sam, the founder,
interviewed 600 developers before he
found his co-founder.
600.
And the way that he did that is the
process that I'm outlining. So, first he
said, "Hey, who here knows anything
about development in his network?" So,
he got he started interviewing those
developers. And then he said, "Hey, can
you introduce me to the best developers
you know?" And so then those people
introduced him because they had a better
contacts. He's like, "I'm not hiring any
of you.
I want to know the best people you
know." And so eventually he kept going
up the ladder of he'll talk to those
people say, "Who's Who's the best one
you know?" And he kept going up and kept
going up only to fact-find, only to find
information until he found somebody who
was like, "Oh my gosh, I this guy has
said more things and made more sense."
And at this point in the process, he'd
already spoken to so many people he had
a good context from which to make a
judgment. And so that is the process. I
will tell you what I personally look for
now.
I look for the quantity and quality of
metrics that someone has to describe
their role. And so I'll give you a
binary example.
So, on one hand, if so I was hiring
someone for customer success. Let's say
that's like you're getting a lot of
churn, you're not getting a lot of
ascensions, you're not getting good
reviews, your NPS scores are low, etc.
You're then saying
"Okay, Mr. customer success candidate,
tell me about customer success.
What metrics do you measure?" Now, if
they say like, "You know, I just want to
make sure people are happy, that they're
having a good you know, the good time,
and that they're you know, they're
getting results and they're having a
good experience." I'd be like, "Cool,
well what do you measure?" And if they
start squirming around like, "Well, what
do you measure?" and they can only come
up with one or two things, then I
already know that this person obviously
can't drive an outcome cuz they can't
even define an outcome.
Now, on the flip side, if that person
says, "Okay, well we like to define an
activation metric up front that we can
do within the first 48 hours."
Then we have like, "What is our time to
value and what's our you know, what's
our North Star there?" We also like to
measure C-Stat, but I don't like to do
it too often because then customers
don't like filling out the surveys. And
so, we want to make sure that we can do
it ideally within the customer journey
during a value-driven exchange that
they're going to have with the customer
service rep or some sort of account rep
that they have to manage, and then we
can just tack it into that process. I
like to look at churn, but churn I see
more as a lagging indicator, and I look
at it and look at these other things,
especially what's our time like? How
long does it take from sale to
onboarding? What's that handoff look
like? What percentage of customers are
backing out in the first 24 hours, 48
hours, 72 and what percentage of these
customers were leaving us a review by
day 30? And so, all of a sudden I'm
like, "Okay, well he just said like nine
different metrics and had reasoning for
that." And said then the follow-up to
this question of understanding the
quality and quantity of the metrics that
someone's going to bring to the table
is, "Awesome. This is going to freak
some people out.
How does what you do make the business
money?"
And if the person cannot accurately
describe how their function cuz every
function of a business makes a business
money. That's why the function exists.
Now, the thing is is that some functions
of a business are indirect versus
direct. So, if I asked a CFO, "How do
you make the business money?" they
should say multiple things. Well, one, I
control expenses. So, everything that I
save goes to the bottom line, and I have
a process of consistently cutting out
excess costs every 30 days. And so, by
doing that, I can usually drive an extra
3 to 5% to the bottom line, which more
than pays for me. So, I'm like, "Okay,
great. They're already even thinking
about my return as an owner versus
them." On top of that, they say, "Okay,
also, I see finance really as a function
of decision-making. And so, if we can
collect the metrics that drive decisions
around what things have the highest
gross margins, what's our utilization
rates,
how can we make the decisions that will
get us the highest return on capital
both human and money capital in the
business, then we will grow faster."
And so, if someone talks like that, then
I'm like, "Okay, they understand how
finance is actually a data function." By
the way, it is. Literally, that's what
my finance does. It gives you reports.
It's reporting.
So, that you can make decisions about
the business so that they we make more
money. Cool. Now, sales is going to say
like and I'll give you an example for a
sales director.
So, if I say, "Hey,
how does what you do make us more
money?" Now, if they say, "Well, we're
I'm going to I'm going to drive sales."
I'd be like, "Well, duh, but like you're
not going to sell anyone cuz you're a
director. So, how do you you make the
company more money?"
What you want them to say is that I'm
going to increase the average conversion
percentage across our leads for the
team.
Because that is the output of the sales
manager is closing percentage. Like at a
fundamental rate, it's closing
percentage is one of the metrics, but
just total conversion rate of leads. So,
if I get 100 leads and there's lots of
mini steps. You got to schedule, you got
to show, you got to close, you got to
offer, whatever. There's cash collected.
There's other mini metrics along the
way, but you just want to see what
percentage of eyeballs and or ear balls
and people who give us their information
we can contact do we convert into sales.
And if you say, "I as a sales director
will be able to increase that
percentage,
then that's the job and that's how I
make the business more money." Because
here's the thing, if they cannot
describe
an output of their job that ties to
revenue for the business or ties to
profit for the business,
then you can be absolutely certain that
they don't know how to do it
and that they're not going to do it for
you cuz they can't even tell you how it
works.
And so, I use those as the litmus test.
One, I interview as many people as I
possibly can so I can get a basis from
which to make a judgment. Two, from
there I'll learn the metrics because I
won't know them um that people use to
describe the role to drive outcomes. And
I will look for the quantity and quality
of metrics that people will track and
what they would do to influence those
metrics. Step two.
And then step three, how does what you
do make the company more money? Don't
let them get away with like with the
sales example, "Well, we're going to
make more sales." No, but how do you you
influence that?
Business truth number three. Things are
hard because your team isn't as good as
you think they are, and that's because
your standards are too low.
Metromind said this to me and I've
always kept this in mind. He said, "Your
best talent you haven't even hired yet.
Your best talent is in the future."
And so, let's run a thought experiment
for a second.
Everybody who's listening to this has
that one teammate who's just an absolute
stud, hopefully. If you don't, I'm sorry
for you. But, at least one person on
your team is pretty good.
If you had 10 of those people, would you
be able to make way more money?
The answer is almost always
unequivocally yes, I'd be able to make
way more money. And so, then the
follow-up is, then why is all of your
attention not to getting more of those
people?
If you listen to the Steve Jobs, the
Bezos's, the the Bill Gates's, Elon's,
so many of them, Zuckerberg, so many of
them talk about talent.
And in the early days of
entrepreneurship, I thought that they
were trying to hide the secrets.
But, it's really that they were talking
about what they're focused on now.
And as I continue to do business,
the more I just care about who rather
than what or how, because if you really
do have the right who, you're one hire
away from somebody who's 100 times
smarter than you, who's done this way
longer than you have, who can help you
grow the business. I'll give you this
story that really drove this home. So,
when we were looking at selling Gym
Launch,
we had a lot of conversations with
investment bankers, and then finally
fixed, you know, we picked an investment
banker to represent us, and then we had
a lot of conversations with prospective
buyers, so acquirers,
um meaning people who like fund
managers, people who have big funds of
money who buy companies for a living.
And I remember
a moment on one of the first of these
meetings where I it was it was in
person, they'd flown out, and all of
their team was on one side, and all of
my team was on the other. And I was
sitting at the head, and the managing
partner was at the other side of the
table. And I just remember just kind of
sitting there silently looking down the
table, looking at both sides back and
forth, back and forth, and being like,
"No wonder these guys are going to make
$3 billion in the next 5 years.
versus my team. And the thing is is to
be clear, that wasn't that my team was
bad. I mean, we built a, you know, $100
million plus business. I saw the
discrepancy. This is not a slight to
anybody on the team. We obviously had
stars. But, seeing the average level of
talent on their team versus mine was a
huge moment for me to understand just
how important people are. And so,
there's a story in Google. I think it
was Larry Page or Sergey Brin, whoever,
typed into Google like parachutes,
whatever. And the ads that came up were
for like buy a radio, buy a car.
And he screenshotted it, and he puts it
on the cork board in the engineering
room and said, "These ads suck." He just
wrote it on the screenshot, and he hit
the board, and he walked out of the
room.
And the story goes that the next night
one of the developers just like stayed
up all night and came up with AdSense.
And AdSense more closely paired what
people were searching for with the ads
that they were shown. He didn't say,
"Here's the 100-step process that we're
going to do to solve this problem." He
just said, "You guys are intelligent.
This is the problem. Go fix it."
And so, one of the telltale signs that
you have bad people on your team or
people who are too dumb or your
standards are too low is that you have
stupid rules. And I And I I'm a I'm a
I'm somebody who's done this. So, this
isn't me preaching here. This is
something that I've I've now realized is
that if you have to ever rule that's
like, "Hey everybody, you have to show
up on time. Hey, don't drink while
you're on the job. Hey,
um like you can't watch Netflix while
you're working. Like that's not a good
thing." By the way, all of these are
rules that I have implemented at some
time in a business that I've owned. And
I'm telling you this now because it
seems so painfully obvious that if I
have to say,
"Don't watch Netflix while you're on a
customer service call with a customer,"
that shouldn't be a rule. That should be
an obvious thing that anyone with half a
brain cell can figure out. But what that
really meant is that if you start making
stupid rules, it's because your
standards are too low and you're hiring
stupid people. Rule number four, lots of
rules means you have dumb people. So,
let's talk about that for a second.
So, one of the things to prevent against
this is a rule from Amazon, which is
that every person you hire, you want to
raise the average bar of the team that
they're getting hired into. I literally
used this yesterday with someone that we
were interviewing.
Uh Leila was like, "What do you think
about this person?" I said, "Well, do
they raise the bar of the team?"
And he was like, "Hmm."
I was like, "All right. Well, then
there's our answer." Because the thing
is is that all companies will, unless
controlled for, dilute down talent. So,
people, you know, sixes will hire fives,
fives will hire us fours, fours will
have higher threes, and people will
always hire people that they're not
threatened from.
Because they want security first. And
so, you have to implement something like
this because the reverse can also be
true. If imagine if every single time
you hired somebody, it raised the bar of
the team, then the team will just
continue to get better and better and
smarter and smarter people, and then the
company will grow and grow and grow. And
I have a fundamental belief that the
level of a business grows kind of like a
Christmas tree, where you've got the the
number and intelligence of brains that
goes up. So, if you have lots and lots
and lots of really intelligent brains,
the the the size of this business is
huge. If you only have one brain that's
intelligent, and everyone underneath of
that has a subset of the skills
of that one brain, then it's only one
brain that's competing against companies
that have a hundred smart brains.
And that was something that in my early
days, every person I hired, I could do
their job better than them, and I
trained them to do everything they did,
which meant the limit of the business
was me. I had to literally keep learning
things, which you always have to do, of
course, but I had to learn everything
from scratch. And so, the business then
had to suffer what a a day one customer
success rep would deal with, because I
didn't know anything about customer
success.
And so
the idea is I would rather bring someone
in who has 10 years of experience in
customer success so that we can start
the business on year 10
of customer success. I want that person
to have learned all those lessons on
someone else's dollar. And then when
they come to me, have all those lessons
so I don't need the scars.
And so one of the one of the telltale
signs also of an early company is that
you've got people who have zero
experience in leadership roles for a
function they've never done before. And
that's because it's like, well, this is
my COO, Sarah. We have five people in
our company, but she's our COO. It's
like, don't use the term COO cuz she's
going to look at salary.com and she's
going to say that she could she'd make
more than the entire company that makes
in revenue, right? No, that's not the
case. Like, she's a manager, right? And
realistically, she probably doesn't
manage the whole business. She probably
just manages this portion of it or he
just manages a portion of it. And so the
thing is is like just because it's your
mom or it's your brother or your best
friend growing up or that guy who you
hired first and has been with you since
the beginning,
it still doesn't mean that they're right
for the role.
And so this is where a lot of the money
that you want to make is on the other
side of a few hard conversations and
many people never have.
They're willing
to just
accept mediocrity at the point of the
bottleneck and never get de-bottlenecked
because they can't say, "Hey Sarah,
I don't think it's working out and I
think it's my fault because I put you in
a position without the resources to win.
And I think and this is how you this is
how I manage it. What I want to do is I
want to keep investing in you. And
here's how I want to do it. I want to
bring someone in who has a ton of
experience. They know more than both of
us put together.
And I want you I'm going to basically
pay for you to learn from this person so
that you can become more skilled in your
career.
And then you I want you to get
laser-focused on this thing over here
that you were doing before and
absolutely tune it up. And so this way
we're you're going to crush what you're
currently doing every day and it's
absolutely within your scope and
experience that I think you can do
really well with it. And I also want to
build out your future by bringing this
person in. So think about it like me
paying $100,000 a year for you to learn
from somebody who has 10 years of
experience.
It's about the biggest gift I can give
you.
And so if you frame it like that, it's
not like this is a demotion or like you
suck. It's like I'm trying to invest in
you and I'm going to invest in you by
bringing this person in who's going to
teach you. Now, if that person has an
ego, which is usually the next common
thing, which is like "Why I thought I
was doing great." Then it means you
probably have a communication issue.
Like you're not telling them that
Sarah's not doing a good job. And then
Sarah gets upset. And the thing is is at
that point, Sarah might have an ego
because she started at the front line
and then became a manager, then you give
her another title progression too fast.
And to be really clear, I've done this
two times
with executive assistants. Um just with
executive assistant within the company's
a zillion times. With me personally,
I've done this and I don't really even
deal with a lot of personnel in general.
And it's like I just I promoted someone
too fast. I think it's the Peter
Principle, which is that people will
advance to the point of incompetency.
And so
someone does really well at sales and so
then you put them in a sales manager.
And then they've never managed a sales
team and they don't do really well at
that, but they get promoted to the point
of incompetency. So I lost a good sales
person and I got a bad sales manager.
And this is how most of corporations are
run. People do well and then their role
changes into something they've never
done before and then they do poorly and
they get stuck there or they get fired.
And most times because the person who
promoted them feels bad, they just get
stuck there. And so you got all these
people who you still have positive
associations with the work that they did
and you feel like you owe them because
they did do a good job one time before,
but now they're doing a poor job because
they're not properly equipped and you
didn't give them the skills to succeed
and they don't have the experience. And
yes, that's your fault. But the thing is
is you can't fire you because you own
the company. So somebody's got to go.
And so either you got to move them
aside, you redefine the role and move
someone ahead of them or you have to get
rid of them.
And again,
this is what makes business hard. It's
not that it's complicated. It's that you
don't want to hurt someone's feelings.
And I get that. That's what makes hard
conversations hard. If you hate
somebody, firing them is very easy. All
right? Like, if someone stole from you,
firing is not
Personal experience there?
I slept fine that night. All right?
It's the conversation with someone that
you know is trying their best,
that you really like as a human being,
but isn't cutting it. And even if you
think you could get them there, you're
not willing to invest the resource to do
it because it doesn't make sense. I
could wait for someone to learn
neurosurgery.
And I think people could, but it might
take a decade. And I don't know if I
really want to invest all that time when
I could just go find a neurosurgeon. And
yeah, I might have to pay more, but I'd
rather pay that than pay 10 years.
And so to to to to loop this back around
to the story that I was talking with the
private equity firms when I was looking
at them, one of the big obvious things
too is that
many of the people on the other side of
the table were making 1 million, 2
million, 5 million dollars a year. And
you know, people who were in their 20s
making 300,000, 500,000 a year. And I
was like,
okay,
I need to reset my bar of what I have to
compensate in order to attract A-level
talent.
And
once I really understood the value of
people,
the way that we grew businesses
completely changed. It stopped being
about building businesses and became way
more about assembling the teams that
build the business. Like one of the core
functions we do at Acquisition.com,
probably the thing that we invest the
most resources into is recruiting
talent. Like there's a reason that we go
really hard on LinkedIn.
Because people respond to our messages.
And we're like, "Hey, you ran all the
ads at this $200 million per year
direct-to-consumer business.
We have a direct-to-consumer business
that's at 20 million. Would you be
willing to take it from 20 to 200
because we think you have the
experience? Or do you know anybody who
does?"
And because we have a following there,
we get the responses and we can get that
level talent. But that level talent's
not coming in for 100 grand a year. You
can moan all you want that oh, these
employees want so much money. But
there's a marketplace. There's a rate.
And if you're not willing to pay it,
there's a company that is smarter than
you that is willing to pay it because
they know the return on it. And I still
think to this day one of the biggest
arbitrage that exist in business
is paying A talent A wages to get 10X
the output. So, let me let me drive this
home.
So,
you can get a B player. Let's say let's
use $100,000 as the baseline. So, I want
to hire a role for $100,000 for this
thing. And a B player in the role will
take 80.
And
uh
a B plus might take 90 or 100.
But there might be an A plus plus guy
who's like 170. It's like whoa,
that's like twice our budget for this
role.
But if that guy or gal
has the output like an A player can get
you 5X, 10X the output of a B player,
meaning
five people who are B players at
$100,000 a year equal one A plus plus at
170.
That's still a great return.
And better than hiring five Bs. And
especially in knowledge work, so if you
have anything that has to do with
thinking and not like where literally
more hands are are required to do the
work, the outsize return on intelligence
is so high that I still see it as one of
the fundamental arbitrage that exist in
business. How much time you save by
hiring somebody who knows exactly what
to do, how drives revenue in the
business, and then you can use 10 years
of experience that you don't have to
pay. So, I would rather pay 25%, 30%
more for somebody 50% more for somebody
who can move me 10 years forward. Like
it seems almost silly when you frame it
like that not to. But the thing is every
day small business owners want to save
$5,000 on an annual on an annual salary
for somebody who they know is perfect
for the job.
This is truth number five. If you want
to get bigger, get better. Better leads
to growth, bigger leads to bloat.
So, I was reading S. Truett Cathy's uh
book Wealth Is It Worth It, and he talks
about the story of Chick-fil-A. And he
said that what his his number one
pursuit um was better, not bigger. And
that he believed that if they were
better, and they just kept getting
better, he said, "Our customers will
demand that we get bigger."
versus trying to get bigger for the sake
of getting bigger. And so, he tells the
story between him, Chick-fil-A, and
Boston Market. So, for those who don't
know, Boston Market was actually a very
big chain when I was growing up um that
grew really, really quickly. And so,
Chick-fil-A was, you know, privately
held. They They took on almost no debt.
Uh they grew really responsibly, one
location at a time. And Boston Market
was like, "We're going to franchise, and
we're going to raise a ton of money from
Wall Street, and we're going to make all
this stuff." And for a period of years,
they outgrew Chick-fil-A by a mile. And
they were like, "Oh, Chick-fil-A's going
to get left in the dust. They're going
to get outcompeted. They're going to get
crushed."
But,
because
Boston Market grew so quickly, because
they didn't They diluted their talent
because they had to hire so many bodies
and not enough brains.
And because they wanted to grow, because
they wanted valuations, they wanted
money, they were what I would consider
mercenaries. Whereas Chick-fil-A and S.
Truett Cathy was a missionary. He
believed in the product. He believed in
the experience. And because he's a
faith-driven entrepreneur, he wanted his
restaurant to represent the tenets of
Christ. This isn't me getting religious
on it, but he believed in his mission.
That's the point. And Bezos talks about
this. He said, "You've got mercenaries,
you've got missionaries." And the
missionaries always win in the long
term. And so, what ended up happening is
that the money guys, some of these guys
cashed out early because stock got
inflated, all the stuff. They took on
tons of debt, and then the the company
ended up bankrupting out of something
like 10 years later. But guess what
happened in that period of time?
Chick-fil-A just kept growing. And the
thing is is that Boston Market couldn't
outcompete Chick-fil-A in their market.
They just grew faster. But the thing is
is that if you've got a Bojangles market
and Chick-fil-A, if you know that your
chicken sandwich is better, you still
always win. It becomes an inevitability.
It doesn't matter if they get there
first. If you win in the end, who cares?
Because quality will always win.
Provided it's priced appropriately and
things like that. But
better leads to bigger. Bigger leads to
bloat. And so this has been something
that was really hard for very hard for
me to learn as an entrepreneur because,
you know, we we like them I mean, I like
the feedback of how much money we're
making this month. I want to make sure
it goes up. I want to make sure it goes
up because that it's a it's a proxy for
growth. Okay. And I used to say this and
I I like it, which is either the
business is growing or I am. So if the
business isn't growing or the business
is going down, I'm growing. I'm learning
what I'm I'm messing up. And if the
business is growing, sometimes you're
not learning because the it you're
getting rewarded for the work that you
did while you were learning while you're
eating
Sometimes you get both and that's the
ideal thing is that it's growing and you
continue to learn and you stick you keep
your learnings ahead of the growth. So
the train's coming and you're building
out the track, you're getting around the
ditches, you're going through the
mountain, you're digging the hole,
you're doing that stuff so the train can
keep running and keep growing.
A big lesson that I have taken from
Chamath Palihapitiya and some of the
best entrepreneurs like Elon. If you're
going to enter a market, so Elon talks
about this. If you're going to enter a
new marketplace, you want to be an order
of magnitude better than
the existing solutions. And so I'll give
you an example Elon just recently did.
Uh he talked about getting into candy or
chocolate, which you might think, why
would he even bother getting into that?
I think it's cuz he had a gripe with
Warren Buffett and Charlie Munger, which
is really sad cuz I like both of them.
He had a little bit of a rift with them.
Oh, he was like, "Well, fine. I'll take
out See's Candies."
And so he was like, "I'm going to get
into chocolate." And so he had all these
people send him different recipes and
all this stuff and he decided not to do
it. And the reason he decided not to do
it is he said that there was no product
there was no version of chocolate or
candies that was an order of magnitude
better than what already existed. So he
just didn't want to play. If you think
about how he entered each of the other
markets, he got into space and was like,
"Oh, we're going to redefine how space
flight works when you use reusable
things and we're going to drive down the
cost 10x compared to the competition."
That's an order of magnitude better.
With cars, the first real Tesla, not the
the Roadster, the high-end one, but the
first one he made for mass commercial
use, was literally the highest rated car
that auto whatever auto magazine, the
premium magazine had ever rated. It got
the highest overall score of all time.
Because he focused so much on making it
order of magnitude better. And the thing
is is that Tesla makes great cars, by
and large. And so, customers have
demanded they get bigger because they
continue to out buy, out purchase their
supply.
And so, that forces supply to increase.
So, you grow.
And so, if you're stuck
and you're like, "I keep trying to grow
and I can't grow." Sometimes you just
have to think,
"Let's not grow."
What if we didn't want to grow at all,
but we just had to make this thing
absolutely insane from a quality
perspective? Just get better. And the
way that you do this tactically is that
you look at each function of the
business and you say, "What's one thing
we can do better?"
That we absolutely very high confidence,
like we're just going to go from
contacting our leads within 30 minutes
to 5 minutes. That's the one thing we're
going to do for the next 12 weeks for
lead for sales. For marketing, what
we're going to do is we're going to make
sure that every single ad has a hook
that's been tested before.
That's what we're going to do. We're
going to make sure every ad that goes
out is going to have a hook that's
tested and we're going to make five
times more of them. Great. That's what
we're doing in marketing. And every
single one of them, here's the key point
is that once you start that new that one
thing, the next quarter you add to that.
You don't just swap it and this is what
most people do. They do that one thing
and then they forget what they were
doing. Is that you end up creating this
checklist of what creates amazing ads.
You create this checklist of what makes
amazing follow-up. You make this
checklist of what makes an amazing
handoff between sales and customer
success. You make this checklist of how
to activate a customer. And so, it's 100
golden BBs, not one silver bullet,
that creates the outsize returns. And
then, once you have 100 golden BBs, you
start getting the word of mouth, you
start getting people who keep buying
from you. And then all of a sudden your
LTV skyrockets. And then you might find
out if your LTV skyrockets, maybe you
don't have a marketing problem. Maybe
you just weren't making enough per
customer. And I can tell you this, the
amount of times I talk to more
businesses who are like,
"We need cheaper leads. We need cheaper
leads. We need We need to lower our
CAC." The reality is,
they just don't make enough per customer
because they're not that good.
And either you're mispriced, which does
happen for sure,
or your thing's not that good.
Which is 100% under your control.
Fundamentally, growth is a lagging
indicator.
The things you do to create growth are
the leading indicators. And the things
that create growth are the things that
make you better.
And so having growth as a desired
behavior is trying to make an outcome
into an input.
And then what happens is you have
growth for growth's sake. And
here's the problem with this just as a
big big picture is that if the reason
that you're in business is to
make money, if that's your real mission,
so many things make money.
And so what happens is you become
distracted as an entrepreneur. This is
why the mercenaries fail compared to the
missionaries. Because if you just want
to make the best chicken sandwich,
anything that's not a chicken sandwich
isn't a priority. They could have
Chick-fil-A credit cards, right? Or
Chick-fil-A miles. They could do that
stuff and it probably make them money.
It's not core. Now, go find out if they
probably have a credit card, who knows.
But like, the point is is that
it's not core to what they know. If
money is the goal, then there are so
many paths to getting there that it's
difficult to stay focused, which is why
companies get spread thin, which is why
they grow for growth's sake, and then
all of a sudden they have five
initiatives that are going on that all
aren't working that well because they
couldn't focus on the thing that
mattered most, which is getting better
at the core promise that they make to
customers.
Business truth number six.
You work all day, but you can't get
anything done because you allow too many
things that don't matter to distract
you.
Sometimes you have to let fires burn.
And so what that means is that you have
to block time for work that moves the
ball forward because a month later it'll
be the only thing you have to show for
the month before.
And so one of the things that took me a
long time to realize is that there are
very few things that are existential
crisis within hours, even within
minutes, right? And so the idea that
everyone in the company and all of your
customers, etc. can have immediate
demand from you as or responses from you
as the owner is not a good expectation
because then it means that you're on
demand for everyone else's needs, but
the business needs you.
And so I'll give you a story to drive
this home. So at my first gym
I had just started sleeping not at my
gym, which was wonderful for me.
And so right as like I get my first few
nights of sleep, I get a call that
everybody hates at 5:30 in the morning
cuz that's when sessions happen. And I
was like, "Hello, what's going on?" And
he said, "I've got bad news." And I
immediately go to
someone died from a heart attack in our
gym. That was the like the immediately
went there.
And I'm just silent and I was like,
"What is it?"
And then he says, "There's a a water
pipe that broke and it's leaking on the
floor."
And I was like, "Okay.
What do you want me to do?"
He's like, "Well, I don't know what to
do. I just I called you." And I said,
"Well, what do you think I'm going to
do?"
He's like,
"I I guess call a plumber."
And I was like, "Okay, what what would I
do in the meantime?" He's like,
"Probably get a bucket." I was like,
"Yeah."
I was like, "Have you done that?" He was
like, "Well, no, I called you." I was
like, "Okay.
Well, why don't you do those first two
things because there's nothing I can
do." There's a story of uh
Eleanor Roosevelt I think uh when I
think someone in her family died in the
middle of the night. She gets woken up
by her servant or whatever, you know,
however they did it back then. And he
says, "You know, Mrs. Roosevelt, I have
some terrible news." And it's like 3:00
in the morning. And she's like, "What is
it?" He's like, "Your cousin, you know,
John died." And she said,
"That could have waited till morning."
There's nothing I can do about it. And
so
there is very few things that will
actually kill a business. And so,
if you allow everything to be urgent, it
means that everything's a priority,
which means nothing is. And priorities
literally mean prior. They come first.
And I literally prioritize my day by the
things that matter most. And so, I start
my day, I do prior
to my day, the thing that I think will
actually move the ball forward. Because
when I look back at my last month to see
the progress that I've made, I never
think about, you know, Susan who I had
to give a refund to because she was
dissatisfied for something. Or we got a
one-star review and we need to, you
know, deal with that. Or
uh you know, our our chat support uh
went down for, you know, 2 hours in the
middle of the day and people were like,
you know, why did the chat support to
like, none of these things are
existential crisis for the business in
the short term. There's almost nothing
that kills a business in the short term.
And like, the only real thing is that
your payment processing goes down, so
you literally your ability to accept
money goes away. But beyond that, like
there's not a lot of stuff. And so, what
you have to get comfortable with is
letting some fires burn.
And being able to say, yes, this sucks,
but not getting the important work done
will suck more. And so, I
spend, and I still do this, the first
four to six hours of my day working on
the things that I believe matter most.
And I think that if I had a single habit
that has gotten me the furthest in my
life, it's that I
I work uninterrupted for the first four
to six hours of my day on the things
that I think have the highest leverage
in the business.
And I like to think about that as,
what's the one thing that if it were
true,
all of my other problems would go away?
And then I put all of my effort into
making that one thing true, or making
that one thing happen.
But that can't happen if you have 20
other mini priorities that are urgent
and not important. Every entrepreneur
suffers from this. And so, you have to
draw a lines in the sand, or you will be
spread too thin. You will work all day
and you will get nothing done.
To protect that first four to six hours,
in the beginning I had to wake up early.
So that meant I woke up at 4, I worked
for 6 hours till 10, and I start my day
at 10. As I made a little bit more
money, I was able to like sleep in until
like 5.
Or, you know, and then start working at
like 6, and then I'd work from 6 to
noon. And so everybody on my team, this
has been for years, everybody on my team
knows there's nothing until the
afternoon. They're like, Alex only takes
meetings in the afternoon. And so for
me, I do my thinking work in the
morning, and then I do my meetings in
the afternoon. As I hired more people,
more directors, more leaders, more
executives, a lot of those meetings also
were able to disappear. And so now it
just became like I have meetings day,
and the remainder of my week is just
completely open. Here, like let me show
you how this plays out in the real
world.
Someone reaches out and says, "Hey, I
got to connect you with Jimmy. I think
you guys would have a lot of synergies.
I think that this would be a really
important connection." And
I say, um, I take meetings on Mondays.
And they're like, "Oh, I don't think you
can do that." And I say, "Okay, I guess
we won't meet."
We just sit there, and that's it. And
you'll be amazed often times that if
they really want to meet you, they'll
make it work on Mondays. And if it means
that it's also 3 Mondays from now, then
it's 3 Mondays from now. And I will say
this, if I don't meet Jimmy, you meet
people out there on Earth. There's 8
billion people. I'm not going to meet
most people. And
the likelihood that Jimmy's going to
actually do something that cuz like if I
know what I need to do to grow my
business,
there's not a lot that Jimmy's going to
offer me there. Like if I'm very clear
on my strategy, and I'm very clear on my
execution, anything that's not that
fundamentally loses me money. It
certainly doesn't make me money. And so
just being okay with
saying no. And so I'll give you the
tactic around this, which is just say, I
like to say, so this is how I do this in
social settings, I'd say, "Hey, I'm
actually not taking meetings until after
my book launches."
And then once my book launches, I'll
say, "I'm not taking meetings until we
sell this company." And I'll just always
have something that I'll just push out
that's really far in advance that seems
very important, that gives people a
social reason to feel okay that I'm
saying no to them, not saying you're not
important, it's saying I've got this
other thing that's really important to
me. Um and so that tends to work pretty
well with entrepreneurs.
But you have to be okay with it. Like if
you have a team where you people manage
your schedule for you,
I like I had to explain this to my we
have three executive assistants that
manage Leila and I's calendars. And
I was like, if I if you put a a meeting
in the morning at like 10:00 a.m., I was
like, you've killed my whole morning.
It's shot. Like I can't get into any
kind of deep work and then I'm going to
have 2 hours and I'm going to have lunch
again and then I'm going to have other
stuff out like no, like we don't do
that. If they are going to do something
and it's quote very urgent and they have
a very strong argument, then I put it
the very end of my day and I and I book
from the back forwards. And so that
means that if I say I want to end my day
at 5:00 or whatever, then it means
they're going to put my my first meeting
the day at 4:00. So from 4:00 to 5:00
if it's an hour-long meeting. And if I
have a second meeting that day, then
it's going to be from 3:00 to 4:00. And
so I still get my whole day until 3:00
uninterrupted so I can work on the
things that matter most. And we have
just learned, Leila and I working
together, that basically the more she
takes off my calendar, the more money we
make.
And that's because that's where I'm most
effective. Now the flip side is Leila is
such an exceptional operator and leader
that her form of productivity is an
actually stacked day so that she can
delegate, invest in the team, prioritize
resources, deal with small small
decisions that have to move the ball
forward, check in on projects, hold
people accountable, reward them for the
the behaviors they've done, like
interview new candidates that we need to
bring into the company. Like that's a
super time consuming something that's
very very high leverage and very high
value. Like think about it. If you have
to take 20 interviews to find the right
person who can then take an entire 20
hours a week off your plate, I mean,
jeez. You spend 20 hours once to get 20
hours a week for life?
What a great return. And this is why
entrepreneurship at the highest levels,
I'm going to go on a side drain here,
but I think it'll be important.
Entrepreneurship at the highest levels
is
always hiring ahead of where you're at.
And for people who don't like their
current business, I can promise you that
if you grow it enough, you're just going
to be dealing with people. All
businesses at the top are you got a
marketing person, you got a sales
person, you got a product person, you
got finance, you got legal, you got
tech.
And that's that's the business. And so
whether you're selling widgets, you're
selling services, you're selling
software, fundamentally, you're just
going to have a bunch of people that are
executing those things. And so at the
very highest levels, business is all the
same.
And you have to learn how to play
business at that level to keep
playing at that level.
Business truth number seven.
Brand takes a long time to build, but
it's the most valuable thing that you
can own. It gives you the ability to get
insane returns on advertising, price far
above the market, and keep people only
buying from you. It's very hard to
imagine something that is better than
that. It just takes time.
And so this was I mean, this is probably
the lesson that took me so long to
learn. Like
you I mean, many many many many years. I
mean, I think I would say it took me a
decade to learn this. And it's I've only
been able to reap the fruit of this in
the last couple years.
And
first off, I didn't even understand what
branding was. Branding is simply an
association people make between
something they know and something they
don't know. The thing they don't know is
your business and the thing they do know
should be something they like. And then
over time, that rubbing of the thing
that they like rubs off on your brand
and eventually you can drop this thing
and only have your company and they will
make that positive association with you.
And so there's three ways that people
will make associations. So that's how
you build a brand. One is what you say
or show, so that's controllable. So
people will associate this hat with me.
And if you got value during this thing,
then you'll associate the value with
acquisition.com. Cool. So that's what I
can say or show. This is advertising. Me
Me making this content is advertising,
right? I'm letting people know about my
stuff.
The second level is what other people
tell them. And so that means like either
someone who's interacted with your
advertising or someone who's interacted
with your product. So it's like, "Hey,
uh I saw this this uh trailer for
Mission Impossible, you know, 306.
And and you're like, I think I'm going
to go see it. Now, if your friend says,
"Oh, I saw it. It was it was bad. Don't
waste your money."
The likelihood that I go see it, if I if
I agree with that person's taste, that's
you know, key side note there. If I tend
to like the same movies they like, then
I would take that really heavily. If
it's like my mom and I don't agree with
movies that she likes, I might just go
see it more because I'm like, "Oh, if
she hated it, I'll probably love it."
Right? And so, what you say as the
company owner is thing one that you can
control the most. Thing two that you
can't really control is what other
people say about your stuff, which then
goes to C or three, which is what the
customer ends up saying once they
experience it. So, it's what you say,
what other people say, and what they
actually experience. And so, as you can
imagine, what they experience is going
to be the strongest thing. So, you see
the ad, you think about going to the
movie. Someone tells you something about
the movie, maybe that influences your
decision. Once you see the movie, then
you you have a much stronger opinion.
And you can see another ad about the
movie, but you're like, "I don't care
what the ad says. I saw the movie. I
bought the sandwich. I went to use their
marketing services." You have a very
informed opinion because you had an
experience. And so, this is why brand
and product are always going to be
interrelated because how do you get what
other people say to be good to your
potential prospects? You make sure that
their experience was exceptional so that
when they do see it, they say, "Hey, the
movie was awesome. You should go see
it." Now, if someone who I like a lot
says, "Hey, the movie was awesome. You
should go see it." and I'm like, "I saw
the ads. I don't think it was that
good." and they're like, "Dude, believe
me. See it." Now, all of a sudden, I had
poor advertising of a high likelihood of
seeing. And then if I go see it and I
say, "Wow, he was so right. This was
awesome." then I'm like, I tell other
people. Now, here's what gets kind of
interesting.
If I go see it and I think it sucks, I
that influences the brand of my friend
who told me about it. Cuz now I don't
actually believe their opinion of movies
anymore. And so, that's why, as a side
note, when people refer people to your
business, they have to be treated so
well because that person who made the
referral risks relational capital. They
risk their personal brand to the friend.
And the reason they make that risk is
they actually want to get a return on
it, right? Like, "Hey, you should see
this movie." because they want the
friend to associate the good experience
with the movie with them.
And that's why people do things. That's
why you do refer products that you
actually like because you want people to
associate or have that problem solved
because of the thing that you connected
them to, right? And so we want to be
that connection and that's how we make
money. Now, if we're thinking long-term
though, from a branding perspective, if
you make a big promise and you deliver
on that promise consistently, people
will say, "Wow, they are what they said
they were." which is one of my biggest
rules of marketing is state the facts
and tell the truth. Don't make promises
you can't keep. And just say, "Hey, this
is why I like using Historic." which is
like, "This is what has happened. I
don't know if it'll happen for you, but
if if you're willing to take that bet,
then there you go." And so if we think
about the things that are some of the
strongest levers in business, price is
the strongest lever on profit of all
things that you can control business. If
you get people to buy something for a
million dollars that other people buy
for $10, you're going to make a lot of
money. And so price is one of the
strongest things that has a lever on
market. And you can measure the strength
of a brand by how much above the
commoditized price or what other
competitors charge you can charge
because of your brand premium. So if you
look at like a Nike versus a generic
brand for t-shirts, shorts, shoes,
basketballs, whatever, they will charge
a premium and they will get that
premium. And so they're able to sell
more units at higher prices
because of their brand and because the
associations people have with them.
And so then the ROI from the brand
becomes how much does it cost me to make
these associations that people find
positive and then you spread that out or
you fractionalize that against how much
of an increase in price you can have
against the commodity. And so if I sell
a million units of something and I can
sell it for $3 above market, then I have
$3 million of excess that that brand
buys me. And so, if I can get an
association that yields me that outcome
for, let's say, I can get a championship
fighter for 250 grand a year to be in my
ads,
then I get a 10:1, or I'll say 300,000
to make the math simple. If I pay
$300,000 that association, and I can now
charge and make $3 million extra, I get
10:1 on that branding. ROAS, you get
return on advertising spend. Absolutely
still All the metrics makes count the
same for branding as they do with direct
response advertising. You just have to
measure over a longer time horizon.
That's the difference. And the And I
will say on a personal level,
branding gets you far better returns on
advertising than anything else. It just
takes longer. And so, think about the
direct response world as like your
paycheck. It's like your You write a
check in, and you get money out. You
write a check in, and the moment you
stop uh spending that money, you stop
making money. Brand is like your
long-term investment. In the beginning,
you you're investing money into your
IRA. You're investing money into your
401k. You're investing money in the
stock market, but it's not really
compounding yet. But the thing is is
that you keep doing that. You keep doing
that. You keep doing that. And all of a
sudden, the compounding starts to become
this monster that you couldn't even You
couldn't even You can't even spend
enough marketing dollars to make up for
that level of compounding. And that's
what happens over time. It just takes
time to get there. But the way that you
control it are that you make sure that
the things that you were saying about
yourself are associated with things that
the people who you're trying to sell to
associate positively. And this happens
in content, and also the people that you
associate with publicly.
The second part that you can control is
how much you deliver on the promise.
Because the experience is always going
to be the heaviest weighted thing that
people have. Now, the approximation of
an experience is a review. Right? The
reason reviews matter so much is because
we see that like, cool, they say they're
great. Now, I go to their site, and I
read reviews to see, are they telling
the truth or not based on approximate
reviews? And then I say, okay, well,
this guy had a one star, but it looks
like he isn't a lot like me. Now, I look
at these other guys. Oh, these are a lot
more like my use case, and they had five
stars. Okay, well, then I feel like my
risk adjusted on making this purchase is
low." Now, I buy it, and then I decide
for myself.
But, the branding is a loop. It helps
make the purchasing decision, and if you
fulfill on that, then guess what they're
not going to do. They took a risk by
buying your product not knowing who you
were. They don't want to take that risk
again. And so, if you deliver on the
promise, they will just buy again from
you even with the premium. And this is
how you start how branding in of itself
can create a competitive moat. People
who buy Apple become Apple buyers. They
just only buy Apple.
And so, even though somebody else's
product might even be better, they don't
want to risk trying it. They don't want
to have the cost of learning a new
interface and all this other stuff.
And so, brand gets you higher returns on
advertising, allows you to price far
above the market, and get people that
once they buy from you, they keep buying
from you. And you do that by what you
say, what other people say, and what
customers experience at the very end
when they use your product. And that
either gets them into the buying loop
again forever, or kicks them out. If you
look at the cutting-edge direct response
world, the strategies that they use
approximate
a brand. And so, let me explain what
that means. So, if you go to quote cold
traffic, people who don't know who you
are, you have no association. Once those
people go into your world, oftentimes,
unless it's like a widget or something
that's a very impulse purchase, you have
something called like a warm-up
sequence, or a nurture sequence, or you
deliver value, or you give lead magnets.
These are all things that actually
approximate branding. So, if I give
someone, let's say, a PDF
that is very valuable, well thought out,
has lots of research in it.
Someone would get a lot of value from
that, and then I approximated a purchase
with them. They get They did an
exchange. They got something, and then
that thing was valuable. And they used
that to extrapolate into what a decision
would be like, or what a product would
be like, if they made a purchase from
you. And so, you have these things like
five-day challenges that people will run
to try and have lots of people for five
days because if you spend, let's say,
five hours with someone, that might be
the same in terms of their warmth to you
or the associations they have with you
as somebody who might have spent a year
consuming a 60-second clip, you know,
twice a week, right? Now, I will say I
think that it's saying that the time
horizon over time actually does have
elements of trust that I won't get into,
but they try to approximate what a
trusting relationship would look like,
which is exactly how you build brand.
But, they just try and condense the time
window. And so, this is why if they want
to sell you swampland, they invite you
to a vacation for free and they spend
two days with you pitching uh swampland
because at the end of two days you're
like, "Wow, I spent 24 hours with this
person. Like, I feel like I can trust
them." And so, they actually build a
reputation in a very minor in a mini way
in a tiny audience to make the sale.
Whereas, if you want to build, in my
opinion,
big big brand, you want to build that
same level of trust across millions of
people. And then when you say, "Hey,
I've got something," they all act as
though they've been with you for two
straight days to make the purchase. And
if you spent two days with someone say,
"Hey, buy my basketball," they'll all
buy it. But, you just do that times a
million. And that's what big brand looks
like. Business truth number eight.
You need to know what inputs and outputs
your money-making system are, broken
down to the absolute smallest action,
and that way you can crank the hell out
of it. So, let me explain.
So, if I say, "All right." So, this
happens all the time. So, we we want to
invest in a company, we come in, and a
lot of times, right, like in we're we're
in like the diligence part of the of the
deal cycle and I say,
"Okay, so you've got five sales guys and
you're spending 5,000 bucks a day on
ads. That's your primary way of getting
leads.
Why aren't we spending 50,000 a day?"
I just ask the question like, "Why like
what stops us from spending 50,000 a
day?"
And then a number of things will come
up. And then the question is how
solvable are these things? Now, if they
say, "Well, whenever we spend more
money, our ROAS goes down." I'd would
"Okay, I would see that as your ads
suck. Great. If they say um we can't
handle the call volume then I'd be like
oh you don't know how to hire recruit
and train sales people. Cool. If they
say oh we could it's just that we
couldn't deliver based on
the promises that we make because we
have a lot of high touch service. So
like okay, so you need to we need to
systematize more stuff on the back end
and get better training in place on the
back end. Ideally maybe bring someone in
who's ruling you know ruling that
owning that rather than the founder
who's split between too many places.
Right? So like you can you can quickly
understand where the constraint of the
business is by simply asking why can't
we 10x this? Right? Now
The skill of an individual is inversely
proportional to how vague your direction
can be.
So let me explain. So if if someone
comes to me and says hey Alex
I have this product can you promote it?
I have no marketing department can you
just promote it? He can just say that or
she can just say that and I will know
everything else that that means.
At the absolute lowest level if you say
that to a five-year-old you'd be like
okay. So this is what promotion means
and there's all these different ways we
can promote and I need you to learn how
to turn on a computer and then this is
how you create an email and this is how
you like you'd have to go step by step
by step and so the more vague your
direction the more skilled the
individuals you need to have in order to
do it which by the way is why smart
people is a great investment because
it's actually more efficient from a
communication perspective. I can say hey
John fix churn
and I can just say fix churn and he
knows all the sub tasks underneath of
it. But over time it's valuable for you
as the entrepreneur to know as much a
much of that dirt as you can so you can
level check and say how good is the
person they're really doing their job
etc. Now let's go to advertising as a
simple example.
Actually let's use the example I had
earlier. So we had three different
problems that I presented. I said why
can't we 10x this thing? So the first
version of the problem was their ads
suck and I say okay, you can't scale
your ROAS there. So, either I So, it's
not just that they're out there. It's
like the the the TAM could be bad as in
like they could be a local market and
you can't 10x your ad spend from 5,000
into 50,000 a day cuz there's just not
that many people in the local market.
But, assuming that that's not the case
and it's just that their ads suck, then
I say, "Okay, walk me through the
process of how you make ads." And so
then what we say is, "Okay, usually you
can nail it down to like you're not
doing enough pre-work and pre-work is
defined as I need you before you start
to sit down and write ads that you're
going to look at the top 20 ads you've
done of all time. You're going to
rewatch them. Step one. Step two, you're
going to go through all the ads that you
saw this week across all your platforms
that you thought were interesting that
you would like to model. Step two. Step
three, you're going to recreate the best
ads you've done. You're literally going
to remake them. Step two, you're going
to take the best ads and just reformat
them. So, old footage, new edit
versus same message, new take.
And then we're also going to create 30
more ads that are completely new net new
takes using the ideas that you had
inspiration from
and just inspiring from old ads that
you've used before that you're not
actually redoing the same messaging.
You're mixing and matching and doing a a
remix, right? And so it's like, "Great.
This is the process and you're going to
do this every week." And so that means
that you're going to spend half a day
prepping and half a day filming every
single week. Now, it's very easy for me
to say when I say, "Hey,
are you doing the ads process that I I
outlined?" They're like, "No, I we are,
but it's it's not really working." I'm
like, "Show me the hooks that you wrote
from the ads that were already working.
Show me the remixes that you did from
the best performers. Show me your album
that you've been saving for all the ads
that you like." If they can't show me
these things, they're not doing the
fundamental actions.
So, that's like example one. If I said
that it was the like they can't scale
the sales team, then I'd say, "Okay, how
do we scale the sales team?" So, oh,
well, we just got to go get people.
Well, what does that actually mean from
an action level? Well, it turns out it
means that we need to reach out to 100
people on LinkedIn in order to get uh
one person hired. Okay, so based on our
churn rate for sales guys, let's say we
lose one person a quarter, whatever,
that happens more with bigger teams as a
side note. Um
So, okay, well, if if we do uh
three reach outs a day over 90 days,
then we're just going to replace our
churn. We're going to have 90 reach outs
to get one good guy, and we're going to
lose one guy. So, we're never going to
grow the team. They're like, "Oh, it's
like so if we need to 10x this team,
then we need to do
well, 100 gets us one,
and we lose a third of a sales rep per
month, which if it's we had a
five-person team, we'd be losing 20% per
month, by the way. You get employee
churn the same way you get customer
churn.
And so, you say, "Okay, so our rate is
20% churn out. Is there things we can
fix that?" Sure, but just for the sake
of this this example, we say, "All
right. So, we need to get, if we want to
double this team this quarter, we need
to do 500 reach outs."
Now, 500 reach outs is going to result
in, call it uh 50 interviews.
And 50 interviews is going to take them
some time. So, we need to take at least,
call it 10, maybe 15 interviews a week
cuz we want to be ahead.
Um because I don't want to get it by the
end. I want to get I want to have these
people done and on board and productive
by the end of this quarter, not just
finished. And so, if you're like, "Wow,
going from five to 10 is a lot." Dude,
we put four we went from zero to 40 in a
company. Like, it's 100% just your
belief set of what's possible. And I
will tell you this right now, this is
just a uh life hack for making more
money.
You will so many entrepreneurs are like,
"You built a five-person sales team, and
you immediately scale whatever business
you do next to a five-person sales team,
and then you stop there." Because you
just don't know how to grow up past
that. And so, you just do what you're
comfortable with. You're a lot of you
guys are comfortable at $1,000 in ad
spend, and you just know how to do that,
and you can't get past that. And so, you
have to break these these these limiters
that you have, and say, "Why can't I
spend 10,000 a day? Why can't I hire 30
sales guys to do outbound in 90 days. I
heard a story
um
of a uh uh multi-billionaire
entrepreneur, ex-Blackstone guy, has
raised billions and millions of dollars,
whatever. And he became
I can't share the company. Um
Company's worth over 100 million now,
and it's not Shopify cuz if you think
about Harley, it's not him.
Um
and he started this new fund, and in
order to start it, and he raised I think
like 20 billion his first lick, like
high-level dude.
What he did was he flew out
I think he did 200 interviews in 7 days.
And so he said, "Everybody come here,
fly out to my warehouse." He had his
team of five killers with him that he
knew from that he took from his last
thing, and he did 200 interviews in 7
days.
And then he got his team to start the
next thing. That's the difference in
terms of level of execution that higher
high-level entrepreneurs do that it
would take a junior entrepreneur 3 years
to do that because they choose to
believe they can only take two
interviews a week. If it is the
constraint of the business, it is your
job.
And so you have to be able to break down
what the inputs of the business are
at the most actual level that yield
output. So figure out the problem, and
then figure out the action that you
actually do, not not the not the output,
the action that you have to do, the
inputs at the most basic level so that
you can crank that out of it.
Business truth number nine, stop looking
for hacks. And I mean hacks differently
than like shortcuts. I mean, you know
when you when you see something and
like, "Oh, the there like start doing
these hashtags cuz that's what's working
really well." Or um
start doing this this new
uh messenger thing that's only going to
work for 60 days.
The thing is is that like if you have to
jump from these little mini trends to
mini trends to mini trends, the moment
that little mini arbitrage thing is
done, you're done.
You want to focus on what the overall
objective of of the platforms that you
advertise on are.
And so
if I know that for example, YouTube
wants people to click and they want them
to watch and ideally watch something
else, then if I just always optimize all
my effort to getting those big things
right, whether something's trending or
like, oh, yellow yellow uh yellow
backgrounds are doing really well in the
short term. We're like, you want to make
sure that you respond to every single
comment well within 6 minutes, otherwise
like it it changes the Anytime someone
tells me algorithm stuff, I basically
ignore it. Because unless the goal of a
platform has fundamentally changed, all
of this other stuff is just is just
distraction. Because again, what's the
one thing that matters most? If I make
something that's so good that everyone
is going to share it and the moment they
watch they can't wait to tell other
people about it,
the platform's going to is going to want
to distribute that. I don't care what
the algorithm is. It's going to want to
distribute that.
And even if it doesn't, so this is a
real talk, even if it doesn't, the 100
people who saw it will get what I want
out of it.
And so, the thing is is that it's so
much better to spend 100 hours making
one exceptional thing than doing 100
things mediocrely. And now, some of
that's like, wait a second, how does
that contradict with you got to do lots
of quantity?
Quantity matters because it teaches you
how much work it takes to create
quality.
And so, once you learn, and this is like
if you look at I like YouTubers because
it's if they have really well-documented
like work cycles and you can see all
their product and marketing in the same
place,
is that
in the beginning many of them make more
videos. And then over time they realize
that if they make a better video, it has
outsize returns, meaning if you make a
video that's 20% better than your
average video, you might get five times
the views. And it might take only twice
as much work to make your video 20%
better. And so then all of a sudden
you're like, oh, well, well, instead of
making two videos, I'll make one that's
20% better and then I'll get five times
the views. And then that becomes the new
standard. Then all of a sudden it's
like, okay, well, now we're
videos of this standard, but if I spend,
you know, twice the time as I did on
that video, I get this video that was
already 20% better another 20% better,
and then that gets five times the views
of the five times the views. And so what
happens is
over time you learn how much work it
takes to make something great.
And that is why quality starts to Over
time,
all these platforms will always optimize
towards quality.
Because there is no lack of information.
Like people have Google. They can find
out whatever they want. What they want
is value per second, not seconds of
value.
And so our job, if we want to make
anything, whether it's a product,
whether it's marketing, whether it's an
ad, whether it's it's a a service that
we give, that we sell,
is that it's I I get so tired of hearing
the entrepreneur story, and I used to be
one of these guys, which is I get so
frustrated. This is me yelling at my
younger self.
Is Is I'm going to like, I provide so
much value. Like there's so much stuff
that I give them. But the internet gives
them literally everything for nothing.
And so it's not that people want more,
they want better. They want us to do the
work ahead of time. People want a
bargain. They want, how can I compress
13 years of business lessons into two
hours? How do I How do I do that? How do
I How do I get the lessons from 35,000
posts in 60 minutes?
They want that. They don't want you to
say, "Hey, you know what? Dude, I put
all 35,000 of my posts inside of this
membership login. It's so much value."
They're not going to get value from it.
Because what would be so much more
valuable is distilling all of that down
to the most concrete form, where every
time they consume it, the value they get
per second is so high they can't stop.
That's where And
when you're thinking about this stuff,
like
quality is in the details that you only
realize with lots of exposure. And I
think about this like coats of paint.
When I write a book,
it's it's not like I sit down and I
write it. I write the first draft, and
then I put another coat of paint on it.
And then I put a third coat of paint on
it, and a fourth coat of paint on it.
And and and I'll say this is a gift I
got from the consulting and and and and
and banking world, which is let me tell
you how they edit. Let me tell you how
it works.
First, you make a deck or a brief or
whatever deliverable you're going to
have to a customer or client.
That's round one.
The second round, you look for just
punctuation errors.
The third round, you look for data
errors.
The fourth round, you look for
misspellings and typos.
The fifth round. Now, all of a sudden,
every time you're reading it, you're
also going to catch other stuff, too,
but you're specifically looking for one
type of thing. And I'm not a video
editor, but I would bet that
this is exactly how you edit video. You
think, "Okay, let's look for lighting
this time. Okay, let's look at
transitions this time. Let's look at
sound and music this time. Let's look at
the actual content itself this time and
make sure that there like there there's
no there's no gaps or space." And so,
it's coats of paint, and that exposure
over time and looking at it when you
when you start early in the morning, and
the second time you look at it, it's
after lunch. The third time you look at
it, you're in a bad mood. And the fourth
time you look at it, you just talked to
your wife about this other thing, and
that's top of mind. And so, you you look
at it through these different frames,
and you get a way It's like sanding down
the rough edges, and you just keep
getting at it, and you put different
level grade sandpaper, so it gets finer
and smoother and smoother. But that only
happens with exposure over time and lots
of licks.
And so, you make the money You make the
money in the edit. You make the money in
the distillation, not in the creation.
And so, stop focusing on the hacks
and put all your effort into the
repeated bouts
and bursts and
going over with the sandpaper and the
second coat and the third coat and the
fourth coat of paint. That is how you
can escape mediocrity.
And that's what everyone who's mediocre
is unwilling to do.
They think that the moment they put the
last period on their document that they
finished writing a book. When really,
they just put 80,000 words into a
document that no one's ever going to
read. And you can teach
quality to people by teaching the
process
that
begets quality.
So, if you say
the first thing we do is we have a
wireframe and every wireframe has to
have
a hook, a story, a list or steps for an
outcome,
and then a conclusion that meets these
standards, that's the wireframe. Have we
done that? Checkbox one. Checkbox two,
we record the whole thing, we fill in
the gaps. Great. Checkbox three, we look
for transitions. Checkbox four, we look
for And so, then they can follow your
step for creating quality, and most
people just never document what they do,
which is why every time they have to
reinvent the wheel, and they have to
reinvent the wheel for every new person
who comes into their company, which is
why it's so taxing when you're small to
bring people on because you feel you
have no training, you have no system.
But, if you can document these things
for yourself, which A, by the way, will
make you better, B, it also make it
easier for you to bring new people in so
you can ultimately replace yourself and
keep the quality where you want it to
be.
Business Truth 10, the best people cost
more, but make you way more than they
cost. It's still one of the biggest
arbitrage opportunities that exist in
business, and I think will continue to
exist in business as long as humans
work, right? And the thing is is that
small business owners never get this.
So, it's really just the big businesses
that are competing for talent. That's
where the talent war happens is at the
top. And do you think there's a
coincidence that the biggest businesses
are the ones that are competing for
talent? Why do you think that is? It's
because they understand that talent is
what makes them a big business. And so,
the thing is is And this is where small
businesses get in trouble again, and I
did this too, is that you have to be
worthy of the level of talent that you
need and have a mission that's aligned
with what they find meaningful. So, um I
have a I I have a an acquaintance that's
in the porn business. I have no moral
qualms. He does legal
Everything he does is legal. Do what you
want.
One of the issues that he has is he's
it's very hard for him to find
high-level talent cuz a lot of people
don't want to work in the porn industry.
And so, I see that as an an as a
hypothetical extreme, but some of you
guys are working one degree less than
that. You're like, "I sell a day trading
thing." It's like, "Oh, so you are
somehow you beat the market." Well,
obviously, if you sell day trading, then
you should just be day trading and not
selling courses on how to day trade if
you were so good at it. And you
definitely wouldn't tell people what the
trades were. Duh, right? And so, the
thing here is the level of talent that
you can attract for that level of
opportunity is going to be very
different from like, "I want to create
something that takes all trash and turns
it into energy."
You're going to get people who are very
mission driven. There's a reason that
every single one of Elon Musk's
businesses is here to save the world.
That's not a mistake. Now, there's two
elements to that. One is that they could
save the world. The second is that
that's what he makes it about.
So, Twitter before this wasn't about
having free speech and civilization. It
was just a social media platform.
But now,
it's
the last beacon or bastion of free
speech. That's what Elon has positioned
it as. Now,
uh ULA, which is United United Launch
Alliance, which is a a government
contracted that does a lot of space
things. You might not have heard of
them.
But SpaceX is how mankind is going to
survive if anything happens to Earth.
And so, we're going to become an
interplanetary species. So, the
likelihood that we can survive any kind
of event if we're a multi-planetary
species goes up for our survival as a
race.
And so, he made SpaceX not about
doing rockets and government
contracting, which although that is how
they make their money, he made it about
saving humanity.
Tesla is about it's electronic cars.
There's a zillion other car companies
that have electronic cars. But why is it
only Tesla is about having this because
it's the future of having Earth be
environmentally friendly.
Every one of his companies he makes
about saving the world. And by doing
that, you get people who will work night
and day to save the world.
And so, I'll give you four little
personal examples that I've had or
sorry, three personal examples that I've
had um around this. I remember when I
had my first $50,000 a year employee cuz
before this I'd only worked with hourly
hourly wage employees at my gyms.
And that one person gave me the time cuz
they could manage my first location to
open up my second location, which made
$250,000 a year in profit. And so, wait,
so I paid $50,000 a year for somebody
out of one location to allow me to open
up my second location made 250,000. I
got five to one on that. Great
investment. Now, somebody might say, oh,
well, why would you give up $50,000 when
you could do that? Well, cuz I want to
make 250 on the next thing.
The second story I had, this is a little
a little bigger, my first $300,000 a
year employee. Guess what they did? This
was my first really really exceptional
salesperson. He brought in $5 million in
sales that year.
I paid him 300 grand.
Was that worth it? Absolutely. Was it
more than I'd ever paid a salesperson
for? Absolutely.
So, it was worth it and it was even more
worth it. My first million dollar
employee immediately in their first 90
days saved me 3 million bucks a year.
Immediately.
And she was like, all right, I just want
to make sure I paid for myself. Now
let's do this other stuff. And then with
her contacts in her Rolodex allowed us
to package our companies and then sell
them through her network
of bankers and private equity firms. And
so, I didn't come from that world. And
so, I hired an executive that had 35
years of experience who had sold who had
been sell side over 40 times because I
was like, I've never done this before.
And so, I found somebody who already
had. Now, I had to pay him a million
dollars a year.
But, was it worth it? More than
anything. And so, the thing is is that
what's crazy is that the stories I just
told you, the arbitrage on value
actually increased as I spent more.
Think about how crazy that is.
A $50,000 got me a 5x. A 300 got me a
14x. A million got me a 50x.
This is why I believe that talent is
still the most underrated biggest
money-making arbitrage opportunity that
exists and the biggest constraint to
getting there is that your company's
and you're
Brutal business truth number 11,
the big obvious thing is the problem,
not the 100 other things.
I want to be clear about this. The
details absolutely matter.
But when I talk to business owners
today, the vast majority of the time, I
can just keep hitting them on this one
question cuz they want to avoid
answering it and I'm like, "Have you
tried your food?
Have you gone through the workouts you
sell?
Have you been a customer of your own
product?"
And more times than not, the answer is
no, not recently.
And they're like, "No, but I don't think
that's the problem." Because a lot of
times, the hard thing is the thing that
hurts your ego the most.
And so there's a quote from Williamson,
uh Chris Williamson, he said, "The magic
you're looking for is the work in the
work you're avoiding."
And I think that's absolutely true also
from a business perspective. Is that
what thing, if it were true, would hurt
your feelings the most?
Often times, that thing is the truth and
it's the one that we're not willing to
face. Like,
let's be real. Your service might not be
that good.
Let's be real. The reason your
restaurant isn't growing isn't because
your SEO isn't updated. It's not because
your website isn't, you know,
optimized. It's because your food sucks.
And the real real is that it might not
even suck. It might just be mediocre.
But the difference between mediocre and
exceptional is those 100 details, but
most people are working on all these
other things beyond the main thing that
matters most.
And so,
I remember Peloton, the story of the
founders, they were talking about how
they were trying to build Peloton. They
said, "What we did is we fundamentally
believe that if we could be the best
part of everyone's day, that if
everybody who came to one of our
workouts left saying, 'That was
unbelievable' and they had to tell
people about it." They're like, "How
good would we have to make it that the
next person they talked to, it was the
first thing they brought up?
And I love that as a litmus test for how
good is the thing that I sell. And so
many people just do anything they can to
have quote something to sell, like some
to sell. But
that's the reason you get stuck. Because
the thing is is that on some level,
whether you admit it or not, you know it
could be better. And that then
influences how hard you push. Because if
you really believed you had the best
pizza in the world, and I hear this all
the time, people are like, "Oh, we're
the absolute best." I'm like, "No,
you're not." Dude, no you're not. Stop
saying it. Because when if you say that,
you're lying.
On some level. And you're lying to other
people and you're lying to yourself. And
so I think most business owners lie to
themselves about how good they are at
the things that they do because
confronting the fact that they're just
insufficient, they're not good enough,
they're inexperienced, they haven't put
enough work in to be good frightens
them. And so then they want to just
scatter their focus to 100 things that
they read online. But
unless the workouts are amazing, unless
the food is exceptional, long-term all
you do is you just let lots of people
know that your food's mediocre.
And that's where thinking about business
in terms of years and decades starts
really paying off because if you believe
that you're going to go big and you want
to go big, then you honestly want as few
people as possible to find out about the
product when it's mediocre rather than
as many people as possible. And so it's
counterintuitive because you have to pay
bills today and tomorrow. And so you
just need to advertise enough that you
can continue to iterate the product. And
then when you nail it, when people are
stoked, when you're starting to grow on
your own
based on the word of mouth because as
soon as people leave your establishment,
they leave your business, they get off a
call with you, whatever it is, they then
can't help but tell everybody they talk
to that day about your thing, that is
when you add the gasoline. That's when
you pour it on.
So, for example, uh my my most recent
investment, school.com,
which is a community platform for
helping people build and monetize
communities,
I had been watching that company since
2018.
And watching what Sam, the founder, was
doing and watching how he was iterating
the product. And when I decided to
become a co-owner of the business, it
was because the business was growing on
its own. It had zero marketing, and it
was growing month after month and had
net growth every single day
based on people telling other people
about the product. And so, that's when I
knew. I was like, "Okay, if this thing
can grow without me,
then how much more will it grow with
me?"
And that's what I want to get into. I
want to get into a business where I
already know the product's exceptional.
I already know it has a
base rate of growth based on word of
mouth, so that now when I introduce
thousands and tens of thousands and
hundreds thousands of people to the
platform, they will associate me with
that value.
And I know that the product will deliver
and then take over from there. They're
not going to buy They might buy because
of the association, but they stay
because of the product.
I've created all of my wealth in four
distinct periods.
In the very beginning with my gym,
I had a 30:1 return on advertising. The
reason that that arbitrage existed,
meaning I put a dollar in and I get $40
out. I put $1,000 in and I get $30,000
out. The reason that arbitrage existed
was because Facebook at the time was
wildly underpriced.
I'm just being very honest. That's why
that first arbitrage happened.
The next arbitrage that occurred was in
Gym Launch, where we got a 100:1 for the
first year. I spent 100 grand and made
$10 million.
Yes.
And as a side note, most of the very
wealthy people that I know had distinct
periods of time where opportunity
presented itself, and then they just
backed the truck up. They just went all
in on that thing. What happens in
between is you make normal money, but
it's those those windows of time where
these opportunities present themselves
where you can just make crazy money.
So, gym launch was 100 to 1.
And the reason it was 100 to 1 was
because the product that I was selling
was the 30 to 1 thing that I had from
the gyms. And so, everybody who became a
licensee then was immediately printing
money in their gym. And the product was
so good, what ended up happening I I say
and so, now I'm going to give you like a
look behind the curtain here.
I say it at 100 to 1, which I did. But,
the reality is I just spent $100,000 and
made 10 million. And a lot of that was
from word of mouth. Because if I had
spent $0, I don't know how much money I
would have made versus spending the 100
grand that I did on ads, but I still
probably would have made a decent amount
of money on zero ad spend because the
people who came in got the result we
promised and then told five other gyms.
And especially in a niche, the people
everyone knows everyone. The smaller the
niche, the smaller the local market, the
more connected it is, and the more word
of mouth matters.
And that's where
you can get these absurd returns. That's
when you get into this like it feels
like printing money because if you have
good margins on the thing and you have
zero cost to acquire or very low cost to
acquire because of the word of mouth,
then it just goes nuts.
And you just like you're like just
accepting money hand over fist. You're
like, "Oh my god, this is unbelievable."
And if anything, that's when you kind of
like throttle back to make sure that you
can consistently keep that word of mouth
and you can deliver on your promises. By
the way, if this is valuable for you or
your team or your executive team, uh
don't be lame. Share the game. Uh this
is how we know that you want us to make
more of this, honestly. Just like we
look at data. The more people share it,
the more we make more of that stuff. And
so, if you're a business owner
specifically, like I'm calling you out.
I'm making my stuff for you.
And so, like please share it so I know
that this is the type of stuff you want.